so tall buildings just collapsing seems
like an ominous sign we don't know what
caused it seems worth finding out
as part of our effort to tell you what's
going on in this country we bring you
this charles burkett is the mayor of
surfside
he joins us tonight mr mayor thanks so
much for coming on
any idea what caused this this is kind
of shocking good evening
buildings buildings like this good
evening buildings like this do not fall
in america
this is a third world phenomenon and uh
it's uh it's shocking we were all
i was out there at uh 1 30 2 o'clock
this morning
and uh it was just a sight that we
never expected to see i thought it was
going to be a balcony that had come off
but it was uh half the building it's
it's a 134 unit building
and approximately half those units are
just gone and
they it fell in two sections you may
have seen it in some video
it was not unlike what happened at the
trade center in 2001
and it's just really disturbing but all
that aside we need to focus right now on
getting people out alive and that's
exactly what we're doing
yes you took the words right out of my
head i didn't articulate what you said
but i was thinking it as you
said it this doesn't happen in america
this is a third world phenomenon
one thing this country is really good at
is rescuing people our first responders
are superb amen
but is there any suspicion at all that
this might have been intentional i mean
you kind of have to say it it's so
strange
we just don't have the luxury right now
to speculate and we're
we're gonna speculate as soon as we get
out as many people as we can
um that's my sole priority we've been
doing that since two o'clock this
morning
we had guys running into a building that
we were told could imminently collapse
so we have heroes uh we have we have all
the resources we need
we're not short on resources we're just
short on good luck and that's what we
need we need a lot more good luck
yes then exactly that's that's kind of
life
i hate to ask you this as bluntly as
this but do you know how many casualties
there are there are casualties there are
casualties and
it's frightening to think of how many
more there are going to be you need to
need to understand that thing came
straight down we used to have 10 feet
between the balconies we now have about
a foot and a half
and they are all lined up perfectly they
just came down one on top of the other
and
it's it's horrifying actually and i
think right now we're starting to
we're starting to get into that
horrifying portion of the recovery
yeah ah but the good news is we've got
we've got
every resource we need and yes thank you
we're gonna we're gonna keep looking
until we find everybody we can possibly
find
mr mayor thank you for this tonight i
appreciate you taking the time
my pleasure thank